okay let's start with the basics  [Music]  [Music]  i'm trying to  fade away  [Music]  crazy  emil could you pass me a ball  [Music]  level 30  that's not the trick  [Music]  good one thanks  [Music]  so  there we go  this is how you receive your own serve  [Music]  [Music]  that was a roller coaster  [Music]  we've got it  [Applause]  crazy  [Music]  guys you know what to do help us reach 2  million subscribers  [Music]  there  [Music]  nice  [Music]  not bad  thanks  three targets three serves  [Music]  [Applause]  it's one way to do it  i think i'll go for this one  [Music]  curve shot around the wall and onto the  cup  [Music]  so the doctor told me not to move that's  not a problem for me  [Music]  it's time for the final freak behind the  back no look 360 counter smash let's do  it  [Music]  [Applause]  did it go in yeah i think  what  remember to hit subscribe and shout out  to that's amazing for this video idea go  and check out their channel until next  time